the mariners ace marco gonzalez is up on
the mound for the series opener if
hewson decides they want to be
aggressive he'll go to his curveball
steal some strikes with the curve and of
course the change up marco was facing
the astros for the first time since
opening day like he jammed him a little
bit weak fly ball out to kyle lewis in
center field
and the lead off man retired how about
the rest and there's two away for the
astros here at the top of the first
inning as this gets fisted out towards
lobes who makes a diving catch for out
number three
lopes flying through the air with the
greatest of ease hauls it in and makes
an outstanding catch plants with colors
junior on the mound for the astros three
and two of the 4.87 era in nine starts
here's the 3-2 on the way and it's
slowing inside it bounces in for ball
four so kyle draws a walk one on with
two down here in the bottom of the first
inning that'll bring up third baseman
kyle seeger a little tapper over the
mound but there is correa in the ship of
the final out of the inning and the
astros have two on with one out on the
hard hit single by tucker now it's
carlos correa's turn batting 261.
he rung him up strike three call
second strikeout for marco tonight two
away all the astros in the lineup nobody
has a higher batting average against
marco gonzalez and josh reddick
we pop up foul ground terence
is there to put it away no score after
one and a half and designated hitter
tonight ty france will lay things off
3-2 again and that's lifted in the short
left field brantley coming in and makes
the bent leg slide and grab nicely done
by michael brantley what a nice casual
sliding catch for michael brantley evan
white leads off against lance mccullers
jr
and add another strikeout to that total
as lance picks up the outside corner for
his second strikeout the two outs now
for j.p crawford their lead off man he's
a shortstop swing and a miss got him for
the final out of the inning
frankly with a
a single in his first at bat rightly
stands close to the plate with marco
gonzalez on the mound and there's a soft
fly ball left field it's going to be a
tough play for marmalajos he won't get
there as braley around first base is
gonna try for second no he's gonna hold
at first base
now the stretch and the two-nothing
pitch to guriel swinging a ground ball
to shore it up with the ball is crawford
underhand toss over to moore at second
there's one the relay to first end time
double play and correa has a chance now
with the runner and scoring position in
a scoreless ball game and the pitch
swinging a broken back ground ball to
hold it short backhanded by crawford the
throw to first right on the money in
time to get korea three and one now to
lewis it got off to a great start this
one in on the hands shallow to right
redick in his tracks puts it away for
the second half
that'll bring up kyle seeger here's the
pitch curveball got him strike three is
mccullars with another one two three
inning that's ten retired in a row now
france flight out to left on a nice
sliding catch by brantley coming in in
the
[Applause]
ball locked it into right center field
drifting to his left mile straw puts it
away jose marmalejos
on the ground altuve in the shift
deep second shallow right makes the play
and there's two outs in the inning first
pitch to luis torrance and that's a
breaking ball popped up
shallow right side foul territory guriel
over on the warning track and he makes
the catch drifting toward the stands
quick inning for lance mccullers jr 13
in a row sent down we're through five
so one out
bregman at first for bradley he's two
for two tonight both of his hits singles
but the lefty hitters are the ones doing
the damage tonight is michael brantley's
three for three and kyle tucker is two
for two two on and two outs for the kyle
tucker now he deals to the play fastball
swing on hit right side right to dylan
moore easy flip over to first in time
and marco survives again white struck
out looking in the third mccullers has
struck out four is retired 15 of 16
hasn't allowed a hit
and a swing and a miss got him with that
change up 14 consecutive batters retired
that brings up tim lowe
swung on driven deep to the gap center
field nobody's going to get a glove on
it one hop against the fence lopez lopes
in full flight and he'll shut it down at
second little one out double breaks the
string of 14 consecutive hitters retired
first hit of the night for the mariners
and they get a chance to take the lead
here in the sixth inning so that'll
leave it up to dylan moore here
line drive caught by correa so the
double is stranded lance mccullers
junior six innings of one hit shutout
baseball lewis draws the four pitch walk
now singer to the plate he's owe for two
altuve has it clank off of his glove
trying to stay with it and seeger is
safe it looked like it was going to be a
double play fortunately for the mariners
turns into an error now the first time
tonight the mariners have stacked base
runners two on nobody out for ty france
france hits it hard and a fair ball
here comes kyle lewis the mariners are
taking the lead
ty france puts the mariners in front and
the bottom of the seventh they get the
first run tonight at one nothing
two outs here is evan white the 2-2
and left field this is carrying back and
this is gone home run
evan white number seven it comes with
two aboard
and he has just knocked lance mccullers
jr out
four nothing mariners
runner at second that'll bring up left
fielder michael brantley he got up
swinging eight scoreless innings for the
bulldog marco gonzalez and that'll load
him up for kyle seeger kyle's still
looking for that 700th career run batted
in nobody out here's the o2 to kyle
swinging a fly ball down the left field
line on the run michael bradley in
toward the corner and i think the ball
is dropped out there by bradley right
behind crawford scoring is dylan moore
kyle seeger has career rbis number 70701
and the mariners have a six-nothing lead
here in the bottom of the eighth inning